all right two quick notes before we jump
in today one yesterday we erroneously
put up a graphic on screen citing that
Montenegro has nuclear weapons I don't
even know where that came from but that
was wrong and I apologize and I stand
corrected also I will be doing a live
stream on our YouTube channel this
evening with analysis of Donald Trump's
State of the Union address which we can
all watch together so I hope you'll join
me then okay we're going to talk about
Venezuela again and as a sort of
reminder there is sort of limited upside
to me talking about Venezuela because
every time I do it angers people it
causes people to unsubscribe there are
paid memberships it's actually sort of
bad in a sense for me to talk about
Venezuela but I think it's important for
me to keep doing it so I'm going to and
yesterday we did one story about a major
military defection in Venezuela from the
Maduro regime we did another story
yesterday pointing out that there are
some problems with the perspective that
some on the American Left are the
positions that some of the American Left
are taking with regard to Venezuela and
the reaction was probably like 15% hey
thanks for doing this the left is
getting some things wrong 30% left
wingers saying I'm just a
neoconservative shill 30% right-wingers
saying I am a left-wing shill for
socialism which was a weird response and
the other 25% of the responses were sort
of like indirect just insults about me
or you know general anti-semitism that
type of thing so there's not like major
upside to this and there are some really
bad talking points floating around and I
just feel as though I'm doing a
disservice to everybody in the audience
if I don't talk about them
and explain the way that I see the
situation now there are those who are
writing in saying David you're clearly
just in the tank and and you're
benefiting from attacking Nicolas Maduro
and Venezuela that's ridiculous I have
no connection to Venezuela or Nicolas
Maduro were not funded by anyone we're
saying that I am for or against the
Maduro regime would be beneficial or
detrimental in any way I mean the sort
of finance
angle is very very silly if that's your
argument though consider for a second
that a lot of the coverage people are
sending me that that they say spot on
about Venezuela is either Venezuelan
funded state media or Russian state
media Russia of course being a direct
supporter of the regime if anyone should
be questioning financial ties related to
coverage it's not me here who's funded
just by my audience
it's them so let's give that talking
point arrest then I heard from others
that my anti Maduro views are because I
am from Argentina but specifically from
Argentina's elite which is of course
wrong I mean my family left Argentina in
1989 with almost literally nothing
because we weren't part of the elite my
family who still lives there sort of
split about Venezuela and Nicolas Maduro
that that's not a very good argument
either so I'm going to examine
everything that we are hearing solely on
the basis of my opinion it's not
influenced by finances or anything else
of the sword and I invite anybody who
thinks it is to point to some evidence
so let's get into a talking point that
is spreading about Venezuela which is
just wrong okay the talking point is
that whatever is going on in Venezuela
that's bad it's because of US sanctions
either significantly because of US
sanctions or mostly or fully because of
US sanctions that is the cause of
Venezuela's economic issues we destroyed
their economy and now we want to take
over their oil and install a new leader
so let's break it down at a general
level Venezuela's poverty was not caused
by the United States and the Opposition
in Venezuela cannot have been concocted
solely by the CIA or neo-cons or whoever
else does the United States have
interests in Latin America of course I'm
against American intervention in Latin
America I'm against neoconservative
regime change plans I'm a progressive so
I'm against all of that stuff but if
there were no significant actual
opposition and many other problems in
Venezuela you wouldn't have the
situation that you have today so let's
now focus in on the sanctions piece this
is a talking point that's on repeat
right
now American sanctions ruined Venezuela
it's simply not true
okay number one the sanctions on
Venezuela are mostly very recent sam
cedar actually had a guest on the
majority report recently a very
interesting interview where the guest
pointed out the economic problems
started way before sanctions were ever
placed on Venezuela and I have a clip
here for you where Ken Livingstone who's
a British politician who is Mayor of
London for a while he's on the was on
the Greater London council he went on
BBC this week and started saying Oh
sanctions sanctions are to blame and
Andrew Neil asked a very precise
question a very specific question
explain which sanctions tell me which
sanctions and of course Ken Livingstone
couldn't name them this is painful to
watch but it's important let's take a
look what if it was true it will be
appalling but what I've watched is
America's imposed sanctions those
sanctions mean that the oil corporation
that name that Chavez imposed when he
nationalized it is losing 11 billion
pounds a year now that's an important
impact on their economy when the US oil
sanctions imposed I come in when it
started I'll tell you all right good
they were opposed this week now now is
the latest no no there until then there
have been no oil sanctions on Venezuela
okay
and it continues and it doesn't get any
better take a look there have been
sanctions on Venezuela just like that
happening on cue but elsewhere there are
on Nicaragua like there on Iran and
these really what they were
international laws tell me what
so the Venezuelan economy has shrunk by
50% and five years what US sanctions
cause that well in the first place there
was the collapse the oil price that was
damaging that's not as American
sanctions then what were these amateur I
don't know I've been retired pensioner
I'm got stuff no no you've been saying
no no this is quite important because as
we speak tonight children in Venezuela
are starving to death
so you say it's you say assumes they
wouldn't be I'm there well which
sanctions they ask they've had sanctions
for years oh no they have
and because that's what the Ambassador
told me all that he may tell you that he
but let me turn the first sanctions were
introduced in 2015 by President Obama so
this goes on for minutes more I won't
play all of it you can find the entire
thing online this is information we can
find right the United States does many
bad things we don't need to defend the
United States but we can't be making
allegations that aren't true there's no
question that the US has been messing
around in Venezuela since the paris
jimenez regime of the mid 50's and and
this as is often the case that was to
fight so called communism that's that's
undeniable but if you want to blame
sanctions for the situation today what
do you mean because in 2005 Bush
designated Venezuela as ignoring
counter-narcotics rules and then
immediately waived the economic
sanctions that would normally go along
with that in 2006 the US was still
Venezuela's most important trading
partner trade grew by something like 35%
in 2006 the u.s. banned the sale of
weapons and defense services to
Venezuela but those aren't economic
sanctions we just can't sell them
weapons in 2014
the House finally passed some economic
sanctions but they were only on
individual Venezuelan officials involved
in mistreating protesters and you can
argue that freezing the assets of some
Venezuelan officials took down their
economy so again examine the talking
points am I for involvement in Venezuela
by the United States no am i for
installing a neocon puppet leader in
Latin America no do I believe that the
purported interim president Juan Y
though is an angel without being worthy
of criticism of course not am i for
rating countries for oil no I'm not am i
financially connected to any of this
stuff mines if anything I'm incentivized
not to talk about this because every
time I do I lose subscribers but this is
the reality and I pointed out yesterday
that American oil companies are pretty
damn happy with the arrangement even if
John Bolton says we want oil that's
horrible but the oil companies aren't
exactly in line with that right now
they're actually pretty happy with the
status quo and the idea that it is
sanctions that brought down Venezuela is
factually indefensible